hello and welcome to this ds9 series
webinar on vitamin d today's
presentation entitled the role of the
laboratory and assessment concerns of
the vitamin D toxicity is being
presented by dr. Reinhold Leif
dr. beet is an emeritus professor at the
University of Toronto in the Department
of Laboratory Medicine and papper
biology as well as in the Department of
nutritional sciences in 2012 he received
the award for research excellence from
the Canadian Society of Clinical
chemists he is an expert on the clinical
nutrition pharmacology and safety of
vitamin d with well over 100
publications on the subject he has
served as an expert advising on vitamin
D related matters for the Institutes of
Medicine and the Centers for Disease
Control in Washington as well as the
American geriatric Society recently he
served on a committee of the Canadian
Academy of Health Sciences advising
Health Canada on ways to modify public
policy in that country in response to
the new rdas for vitamin D there's been
a principal investigator on many
clinical trials involving vitamin D and
maintains a deep interest in the
difficulties in evidence-based medicine
faces when it comes to deciding on the
role of nutrients particularly vitamin d
for the Prevention of disease when Apple
I can introduce you to dr. these
oh good afternoon thank you for having
me talk to you about one of my favorite
topics safety of vitamin D in the role
of vitamin D it's regard to toxicity and
I think one thing that in many people
chemists really often have to deal with
is at what point do you tell a user of
your lab test that they've got a lab
result that's potentially risky vitamin
D is very interesting because like most
things anything that actually works in
your body whether it's water salt sugar
protein it may do benefit by its aim to
open too much of it will be doing harm
to you and paracelsus is the classic
toxicologists other toxicology to some
on who came up with this concept because
vitamin D is really quite potent one
milligram encompasses 40,000 units of
vitamin D people in the past have
misused it and this slide is a toxicity
study basically it's a form of
meta-analysis from the year 1948 and the
thing that I wish to draw your attention
to are the doses that at that time were
associated with toxicity toxicity of
vitamin D relates largely to
hypercalcemia what hypercalcemia does it
effectively dehydrates you on symptoms
our thirst anorexia vomiting etc you can
miss diagnose it hypercalcemia you need
a blood test basically to confirm it
it's a high serum calcium that's causing
the harm some years ago I was involved
with an investigation a kind of a
mystery this was a young man who
presented in the emergency ward with the
symptoms you see right here
conjunctivitis thirst vomiting and when
he went to emergency initially he was
dismissed as presumptive gastro
and Titus he would get better soon not
long afterwards however and I guess
actually the top of the slides a
giveaway here both the son and the
father were being poisoned by somebody
who was somehow adding crystalline
vitamin D to table sugar crystalline
vitamin D looks very much like the South
Korea the crystals of sugar ik so you
can mix it in nicely and intoxicate
people the father's calcium after having
presented similarly was well above the
reference range we have SI units in
Canada so you can see our reference
range for calcium is up to a unit called
2.65 and this was well above it the
serum 25 hydroxy D level was 1555 nano
moles per liter which came as a shock
and the hormone made from vitamin D was
essentially high normal not that much
going on and no matter what unit you're
looking at this is clearly a case of
vitamin D toxicity now the serum calcium
was even more interesting because you
know you can measure 25 hydroxy by UV
detection HPLC and the serum level again
in the young man when he was brought
back was 1555 sorry the father but the
unmetabolized vitamin D was a peak that
was alluding here something that was
quite spectacular unmetabolized vitamin
D was 17,000 animals for leader which
works out to being the 6800 nanograms
per milliliter a thorough severe
toxicity on both of the individual is
eventually recovered and you know it was
not a really long-term problem with an
acute problem so I want to go back just
to give you more context about vitamin D
and you know like with all lab tests
that we do we have the question of what
is the reference range or what is normal
for vitamin D and again I've done
literature reviews in primates humans
are of course a primate species and if
you have healthy apes in my
he's their serum 25 hydroxy D levels are
typically higher than 18 animals per
liter or that works out to 32 nanograms
per milliliter so if you had a healthy a
poor monkey you'd want your blood test
result in that monkey to be higher than
32 these are of course box plots the box
indicates the median and the 75th and
25th percentiles of my whiskers indicate
the highest and lowest numbers that are
not statistical outliers people who work
outdoors or who are lifeguards or who
attend suntan parlors again have 25
hydroxy D levels that exceed 18 animals
leader or IE exceed 30 to the nanograms
per milliliter some years ago when we
were setting up these methods for 25
hydroxy a hospital lab in Toronto 43
degrees north latitude it's the same
latitude as Omaha or Boston our lab
personnel in wintertime had an average
25 hydroxy level of 14 animals per meter
or 16 nanograms per milliliter we did a
clinical trial looking at different
intake levels for five months after five
months on a thousand units per day you
can see what the blood levels achieved
and on 4000 units per day the vitamin D
produced a blood level at the far right
it was not unreasonable for somebody who
would have been an outdoor worker in
other words the contention is that if
you are an outdoor worker exposing a
substantial portion of your skin to
sunshine you're requiring about 4,000
units of vitamin D per day rickets is
the classic disease I guess in children
that relates to vitamin D deficiency and
the diagnostic threshold for vitamin D
deficiency rickets is 25 nano moles per
liter or 10 nanograms per milliliter in
the 1970s people were really doing a lot
of research and TCB stamp published this
article in The Lancet 1977 where they
used various doses of vitamin D and had
one group that was going to suntan
parlors a couple of times a week in the
intro
singing noise the 25 hydroxy be blood
level increase in the Tanners at a rate
that was the same as adults taking 2000
sorry 250 micrograms of vitamin D per
day 250 micrograms of bull Calcifer all
or vitamin D is the same as 10,000 units
so in other words if you're acquiring
abundant sunshine you're acquiring
vitamin D at a rate equivalent to taking
10,000 units of vitamin D by mouth
now remember which regard to vitamin d
most things relate to log those response
relationships and classically the reason
you take vitamin D or provided to your
baby is for bone health there are
emerging issues with regard to other
kinds of functions therican functions
etc I can't go into those toxicity is
what we're concerned with and toxicity
is much higher on the dose response
curve as you will see in other words
verging up to a thousand micrograms per
day in other words about one milligram
per day which is about the same as
40,000 units per day and above on a
long-term basis would make you start to
worry about health with regard to the
vitamin D incidentally the port of milk
contains 400 international units a
hundred units for top of milk 400
international units of vitamin DS the
same is twenty five nanograms per
milliliter it's not a huge amount but if
this is a kind of a context issue I want
to provide more background context on
serum 25 hydroxy vitamin D firstly 25
hydroxy D is that thing that you measure
in order to assess vitamin D nutrition
vitamin D by itself disappears out of
circulation so quickly that it's not
something that we would measure as
anything meaning and incidentally when
can you make vitamin D do you need
wintertime sunshine etc a rule of thumb
is you need according to weatherman a UV
index of 3 and at lower altitudes
you know sea level or Boston's altitude
when your shadow is the same length as
your height
the UV index is three and if your shadow
is longer than your height then you
don't have enough ultraviolet light
intensity to produce a meaningful suntan
and you don't have enough to produce a
meaningful amount of vitamin D in other
words your shadow has to be shorter than
your height and if not you're in a
vitamin D winter another interesting
aspect of a skin and vitamin D is that
you know if you think about it the
natural default color of the human
species we evolved originally around
Ethiopia in the Horn of Africa and the
natural color of human skin is black
black skin but as people migrated north
were door southward through the world
there was some selection for lighter
colored skin and it's thought that the
reason for this is that lighter skin
provides less natural sun protection
factor a black African from Nigeria has
a built in black skin that provides an
SPF factor sun protection factor of
about six so it's almost like there have
a built-in suntan lotion or as a white
person has less protection and greater
ability to make vitamin D at northern
latitudes that protected adults children
from the conditions of vitamin D
deficiency we did a survey a couple of
them of University of Toronto students
we have a university that's probably not
unlike most universities across the
United States that's quite diverse and
here you see the box plots for a serum
25 hydroxy D levels for various ethnic
racial groups the most interesting
aspect is that Europeans are the
outliers they have 25 hydroxy D levels
of around 60 6-0 nanomoles per liter
which works out to about twenty five
nanograms per milliliter during the
winter others have lower levels and as I
stated before if you wanted to diagnose
rickets
twenty
5 nano moles per liter or 10 nanograms
per milliliter and below is diagnostic
of rickets so look at these non-european
individuals easily 25 percent of them
have 25 hydroxy D levels that by
anybody's definition should be at some
severe concern if I think about the
vitamin D system I think about body
compartments and pharmacokinetics and I
just sort of want to review it for you
think about vitamin D is entering your
bloodstream and from there it dissipates
into a large volume of distribution both
muscle tissue and into adipose tissue it
disappears the half-life of about 2 days
it's not strongly bound to vitamin D
binding protein and what's left is
readily converted to 25 hydroxy vitamin
D 25 hydroxy vitamin D has again a
relatively large volume of distribution
and it's half-life is at least two weeks
up to about four weeks depending on the
study it's very very tightly bound to a
specific carrier protein called vitamin
D binding protein and that vitamin D
binding protein has the capacity to
carry 4,300 nano moles per liter of
vitamin D in other words more than 44 0
times the amount of vitamin D as is
present in the bloodstream the kidney is
an endocrine gland and it releases 125
dihydroxy vitamin B into the bloodstream
in order to help your intestines absorb
calcium better this 125 D has a
half-life of about half a day 12 hours
it's not strongly bound to vitamin D
binding protein and it's frequently
given to kidney patients nephrologist
often use the word vitamin D but what
they mean is 125 dihydroxy vitamin D
when they give it lastly 24
hydroxylation breaks off the cholesterol
like side chain of the vitamin B
molecule is producing something called
calcitriol like acid that clears out
into the urine eventually so has a
laboratory in your always face
reference values you understand the
reference value system or any lab test
yet apparently healthy individuals and
you take the ninety middle ninety-five
percent of that population and their
levels are what we consider reference or
perhaps normal values but for vitamin D
again you know what kind of individuals
are we looking at what season etc so
it's difficult to come up with reference
values but the one reference value
that's also quite important is the toxic
level because there sunshine by itself
has never been implicated as pausing
vitamin D toxicity but people can go to
the drug store or the health food store
and buy all the vitamin D they want at
least in the United States and then
eventually you know one has to risk
toxicity and the physician will want to
know from you what 25 hydroxy D level is
consistent with toxicity first thing to
point out is toxicity classically for
vitamin D relates to a high serum
calcium caused by a high vitamin D to a
lesser extent hypercalcemia as I
indicated remember
you know calcium is an interesting
compound because it's one of those very
few compounds where the efficiency of
your intestinal absorption depends on
how much you're eating if you eat a lot
of calcium
you're not going to absorb it
efficiently because your body only wants
to absorb around 200 milligrams of
calcium per day on the other hand if
your dietary calcium is about 300
milligrams then you're going to have
quite a high efficiency of absorption to
try to sustain that 200 milligrams per
day number if you eat too much calcium
of course you're sustaining your plasma
calcium and there's a you know
relatively defined amount of calcium
that goes into the urine you know an
adult is in calcium equilibrium if you
absorb more calcium from your food it's
going to basically end up in the urine
you don't want hyper calcium if you have
vitamin D toxicity it's driving
intestinal calcium absorption
excessively the first sign or symptom of
vitamin D toxicity is a high urine
calcium because basically the kidney
function
as a spillover process or excessive
calcium that was absorbed from your food
it's only once that kidney capacity is
limited and overrun that you become
hypercalcemia and symptomatic due to
high serum calcium levels Robert he's
done quite a bit of work trying to
assess threshold levels for vitamin D
and he's here put together a bit of a
meta-analysis of various trials and on
the y-axis you see the fractional
absorption of calcium in groups at
various 25 hydroxy D levels and what
he's come up with is a threshold or cut
point as you take more vitamin D and as
your 25 hydroxy level rises up toward 32
nanograms per milliliter intestinal
calcium absorption increases but once
you're beyond 32 nanograms per
milliliter you've satisfied the need for
vitamin d to control calcium absorption
and you'd have no further changes we did
an early phase study one reason I did
more clinical trials on vitamin D is
that nobody's really looked at the
vitamin D system in the past as if it
were a drug and of course when you have
a drug what you need is the phase one
safety studies the phase two what does
it do type studies in Phase three or it
really does it improve disease outcomes
type studies so what you've got here is
one of a couple of clinical trials that
we've looked at with regard to multiple
sclerosis these individuals were active
patients with multiple sclerosis and we
were looking to see whether vitamin D
might do something but here we have
safety factors throughout this study
they were taking 1200 milligrams
elemental calcium every day is worst
case scenario we're giving them a high
calcium intake and then giving them high
amounts of vitamin D at the very
beginning we've got roughly a month of
baseline levels these are again box
thoughts of the groups 25 hydroxy D
levels we started on a month of calcium
and if there was no hypercalcemia or
hypercalcemia we moved on to
four thousand units per day that's
indicated there by a hundred micrograms
per day if that was okay a month later
we moved it up to two hundred milligrams
micrograms per day four hundred
micrograms per day and then toward the
end of the study we bought a month of
800 micrograms per day which is 32,000
units in the last month of the study if
they hadn't become hypercalcemia yet a
thousand micrograms of vitamin d 40,000
units per day for a month so what point
this was kind of scary work is we were
fearful that something adverse would
happen as I mentioned earlier you know
urine calcium is the canary in the mind
the first thing that you would see go
wrong if people are becoming vitamin B
intoxicated
um one measure they regard as a very
nice and efficient and easy measure is
the ratio of calcium to creatinine I
measure these things in SI units Nili
more per milli more but American units
are are different one point zero ratio
on mic SI scale is equal to 0.38
milligram per milligram calcium in the
urine concentration divided by
creatinine in the urine concentration is
an important number 0.3 milligram per
milligram is the point above which one
would categorize the patient as having
height for a urea as you can see as you
go from left to right in this figure at
the bottom I show the average 25 hydroxy
D levels up to 162 manna grams per
milliliter and at the top there was no
indication that you're in calcium is
rising in the groups of individuals and
likewise at the bottom the serum calcium
didn't change either recognize that the
protocol here was an accelerated
protocol I'm not saying here that 40,000
units or 100 microgram micrograms per
day was safe we had to do this because
of the long half-life of vitamin D
remember the 25 hydroxy D as a half way
if you are
intoxicated the half-life of losing
vitamin D out of your body is about two
months by the same token in pharmacology
in order to get to an equilibrium you
have to have a patient on a given dose
for these four half-lives
so we went through a rapid dose
escalation study we never reach the
final threshold levels of 25 B for the
dosa state but you can see nothing
happened up to the levels achieved so
again this is Robert Heaney's data the
question is is there any sign that as he
keep raising the 25 hydroxy B that may
be hydrocal Syria would start we did
many multiple sclerosis patients on high
doses of vitamin D and what we did was
on this graph show the serum 25 hydroxy
levels achieved in those patients and
the line that you see here is not a
regression line rather a nonparametric
process called low a lowest fought
nonparametric goes linear scatterplot
smoothing so these were cut points that
were not decided by me but by the
computer going up from low 25 hydraulic
cities upwards remember the urine
calcium to creatinine ratio on the
y-axis is analogous to a calcium
absorption value because that calcium
you absorb does end up in the urine and
you can see that ratio I mentioned
earlier here in milligram per milligram
0.38 the magic number for hyper calcium
just as Robert Heaney had indicated
earlier up to about 32 nanograms per
milliliter we had a rise in calcium
absorption efficiency or urinary calcium
as we went up higher through the
reference range there was no further
increase in urine calcium and then
finally once we exceeded a hundred
nanograms per milliliter there was a
statistical upward tick but not quite
enough to produce hyper cal syria there
were some of course hypercalcemia sees
that you
for example at the far right top on his
figured but when those patients were
repeated their urine calcium's were
normal so there's the first hint of
vitamin D toxicity not yet toxic but if
you want it to be very conservative with
regard to your lab reports where should
you start to be concerned it would be a
hundred nanograms per milliliter I ate
two hundred and fifty nanomoles per
liter or higher we've done further work
reviewing the literature the previous
was one of my clinical trials this is
essentially a meta-analysis where the
circled figures indicate results for a
group that was taking a high dose of
vitamin D those the vitamin D are shown
on the x-axis here it happens to be in
micrograms per day remember a thousand
micrograms per day is forty four zero
thousand international units ten
micrograms per day the far left is the
amount they'd have imported milk the X's
indicate case reports of people that
were proven to have hypercalcemia
together with a high serum 25 hydroxy D
blood level what's interesting point out
here are the data at the top left of
that zone there are groups of
individuals who we're taking what is for
some people a toxic dose but nobody in
that group those white dots was
hypercalcemia as such in other words
there's a bit of a gray area
some people Navy if you want to call it
that hypersensitive to vitamin D some
individuals with renal failure
whose kidneys cannot excrete the amount
of calcium that is being absorbed from
the intestine may become hypercalcemia
with excessive levels of vitamin D some
people with thyroid like condition there
is there are some individuals who have
tuberculosis type conditions where there
is non renal one hydroxylase that is
inappropriately putting out the vitamin
e hormone 125 E and those can also
become hyper Tahseen
so here I'm getting it what a lot of
people regard as you know the risky
threshold when it comes to dietary
advice
food and nutrition Boyer the Institute
and the Institute of Medicine have a
definition for the tolerable upper
intake level this is a level nutrient
intake a healthy person could take
without a doctor's supervision and he
reasonably assured that there's no harm
you're going to happen here I consider
it a safe level on current policy for
institute of medicine and most
governments indicates that the tolerable
upper intake level for vitamin D is four
thousand international units per day and
as a rule of thumb I have had you know
in my experience four thousand
international units of vitamin D in the
long run will raise your 25 hydroxy
level by about a hundred nano moles per
liter or 40 nanograms per milliliter and
that's of course the middle of a box lot
with upper and lower levels around that
so again these are the way dietitians
learn their work if you're looking for a
you know establishing a dietary
recommended allowance or something on
the left you're worried about the risk
of harm things like rickets or
osculation
perhaps osteoporosis and at the far
right as I indicate anything that does
good for you is going to do harm I'm
trying to figure out where is that
harmful level so we can establish you
know what's safe so for vitamin D for
what from the time you're born onward
you should have at least 400 units of
vitamin B newborn baby RDA
is 400 units per day from 1 year of age
up to 70 years of age the RDA is 600
international units of vitamin B per day
and for individual is greater than 70
years of age the RDA recommended dietary
allowance is 800 international units of
vitamin D per day if you wanted to
poison somebody and intentionally hurt
them how would you do it as I showed in
the earlier slide of the people being
intoxicated
you have to go at least 50,000 units per
day one or two days isn't gonna do it
you've got to do it for many days so a
month of 50,000 units per day I would
not get I would take it less the no
observed adverse effect level for
vitamin B is in the vicinity that you
could get with sunshine other words
10,000 units vitamin D per day is
something that's probably not going to
do you any harm but there's a policy
basis you put an uncertainty factor a
safety factor into that and what you
tell the public and so a safety factor
of two and a half two point five is
divided into 10,000 producing an upper
level that tolerable upper level I told
you about earlier so the purpose of an
RDA remember is to provide food advice
and what the Institute of Medicine also
targets that recommended dietary
allowance to be is a dose that if
everybody were to be taking it should
give them a 25 hydroxy B blood level of
at least 20 nanograms per milliliter
they saw at least the best research that
people seem to be able to put together
that's essentially on top of the
prevailing intake etc now getting back
to the pharmacology of vitamin B in the
early 1970s barber Mawr in the United
Kingdom had terminally ill patients
provide permission to use their body for
medical research and what they were
given was radioactive vitamin D and then
their tissues were extracted and the
radioactive vitamin D was measured in
those tissues on the left you can see
that yes per gram or per kilogram that
takes up a fair bit of vitamin D muscle
s but on the other hand you have more
muscle tissue than fat tissue in most
individuals and on the right you can see
most of them for half of the vitamin D
distributed into muscle half of it into
fat and some into serum so it's not true
that vitamin D is inherently a fat
soluble compound it's in muscle and fat
and you get it also in the meat that you
eat depending on how much vitamin D was
provided to those animals for example
salmon per se don't make vitamin D
salmon get their vitamin D by eating
microorganisms or plankton near the
surface of oceans that Zul plankton
acquires vitamin D salmon eat it you eat
the salmon and you get the vitamin D
from that salmon so it's all include
chain this was a nice study that was
reported by Pettit for in the 1990s
about a family that stole some oil it
was actually a vitamin D concentrate oil
stolen by a South African family and
they use that oil for cooking
unfortunately they became intoxicated
with vitamin D and this is just simply
to start showing the blood levels that
were achieved so on the x-axis you see
blood levels and on the y-axis various
outcomes that bar that I'm showing you
there indicates the reference value for
the analyte being shown okay so you can
see that for example the second box from
the bottom plasma calcium became toxic
once they got a plasma level over 500
nanograms sorry above about 300
nanograms per milliliter so you can see
that the percent free 125 went up not
total but free serum calcium went up
again well over 200 nanograms per
milliliter the total of 125 D level
hardly changed because 125 B is a
hormone its production is relatively
regulated but one reason why the free
level goes up is when you get so much
vitamin D into the bloodstream
it displaces the 125 off of its carrier
protein and that free 125 is what I
consider the mechanism that creates the
toxicity in the end so this is a nice
little figure you can dis if you know
above 200 nanograms per milliliter of
vitamin D it's a number that is
definitely risking toxicity
so again this is just a cartoon I guess
I put it in because I like it normally
you have relatively small proportion of
the 125 hitting the intestine and if
you've got tons of vitamin D present
much more of a proportion of 125 hits
the target issues and cause thoughts to
see everything because I thought it's a
pretty good smile
so it's regard to vitamin D toxicity
vitamin D binding protein has a
saturable capacity it's it's a large
capacity you start to produce
hypercalcemia once you're 25 hydraulics
these are over 500 nanometer that's the
same as greater than 200 nanograms 4
milliliters and vitamin D systems
interesting I haven't mentioned it very
much but unlike most of the endocrine
system the vitamin D enzymes are
functioning below their km in other
words if you put in twice the product
the system has to adapt otherwise sorry
if you put in twice the substrate the
system has to adapt and produce twice
the product I'm sorry if we're talking
so fast my self-conscious nature here
it's the too much 125 P in the free form
that is the mechanism of harm there are
some sensitive populations with
sarcoidosis may most don't but some may
have the capacity to produce 125 B from
an online or site and spill it into the
bloodstream
Michael bacterium tuberculosis again is
similar where he may have too much 125
there is a theoretical concern about by
azide diuretics because they prevent the
urinary excretion of calcium and
therefore you may not have the ability
of the kidney to you know throw out that
extra calcium sorry for this
crazy-looking figure but this is a case
report of a woman who was prescribed 20
vitamin D 2 as 50,000 units to take it
once a week but unfortunately for
several years she took it once a day for
25 hydroxy D level
sometimes of course there was serum
calcium going up and when what I'm
trying to show sorry for the craziness
is the line there that line indicates
the 25 hydroxy D blood level I consider
a little bit inappropriate this
laboratory refused to dilute a high
serum 25 hydroxy B blood level so for
the better part of two years we didn't
actually know what her blood level was
we just knew that was above 250
nanometer but it took the better part of
two years for the problem to resolve I
think that's been helpful to this lady
into the physicians if the lab had gone
to the trouble of diluting it but
sometimes I guess financial things are
taking priority over actually helping
the customer treatment for vitamin D
toxicity you can see here pamidronate is
a dis phosphonate it's a drug that
prevents bone from reserving prednisone
is a steroid it also antagonizes the
action of vitamin d and resilient Nate
is another it's a serum it's an agent
that reduces bone turnover so basically
you're trying to stop or turnover bone
resorption from happening and of course
to keep dietary calcium to a lower level
than too many cows are getting in the
system at this point what I'd like to do
is summarize the gist of the talk I've
just given from the laboratories point
of view toxicity of vitamin D requires
hypercalcemia to be present along with
an elevated 25 hydroxy d there is no
proof of vitamin D toxicity unless you
have hypercalcemia and perhaps to a
lesser degree hypercalcemia um
the lab user of course wants a number
for the 25 hydroxy D level and for that
I guess the numbers would go as follows
according the Institute Institutes of
Medicine you're getting your recommended
dietary allowance of vitamin D if you're
a serum 25 hydroxy D is at least 20
nanograms per milliliter
furthermore 25 hydroxy levels up to 109
grams per milliliter are consistent with
high level of sunshine exposure and they
can be achieved without taking a vitamin
D supplement super physiological levels
of 25 hydroxy D can occur when you have
extra supplement intakes and this means
substantially more than 4,000 units per
day if we consider further what level of
25 hydroxy D would you say is harmful
toxic the paper by Pettiford that I
reviewed earlier indicated that starting
at around 200 nanograms per milliliter
there is clear risk of having higher
urine calcium higher serum calcium
happening so essentially I would say at
least 200 nanograms per milliliter is
the toxic level 100 nanograms per
milliliter is the top of the
physiological range if the toxic level
is exceeded then basically you have to
discontinue the vitamin D and avoid
inappropriate doses of vitamin D intakes
the next couple of slides are more
supplementary if you really want to know
more about the official line with regard
to vitamin D all you have to do is glue
bilder words Dietary Reference Intakes
for calcium and vitamin D and you'll
come up with this a National Academy of
Sciences press book it's 460 pages of
very ethical overview of the vitamin D
system and the guidelines so far as
dietary principles are concerned
basically again they also state that the
hallmark of vitamin D toxicity is
hypercalcemia associated with high serum
25 hydroxy levels and by that we mean
level is higher than 200 nanograms per
milliliter
the Institute of Medicine numbers you
can see in their table here a table of
635 and again it's kind of a gray area
almost like dimmer lights getting turned
down before you say well when is the
level off or on its harmful and
according to their numbers around 375
150 nanograms per milliliter limit the
thing that is emerging at least
according to some individuals is
epidemiology that looks at
cross-sectional surveys and they suggest
on occasion for some outcomes but not
most outcomes a j-shaped or a u-shaped
risk where they may there may be a
statistical rise at the very highest
quintile or for trial of 25 d level it's
emerging but these other jc8 u-shaped
risks are not anything that the
laboratory has to be concerned about
it's something that is still in the
works and one it work needs to be done
on that but at this point I'm happy to
be open to questions and look forward to
answering thank you there's a white
individual development irresistible as a
black individual after Sun Tanning yeah
basically suntan is a form of building
up you know protection against sunshine
I think it's more a protection against
you know for the skin but a Clinton is a
sign that you are acquiring UV light and
adapting to it not everybody depends
very well does the vitamin D levels have
anything to do with fingernail house
fingernail splitting etc it's an
interesting question nobody's done
trials on that but I've heard
anecdotally people talking about that
someone has asked how about cofactors
with regard to vitamin d like magnesium
and vitamin K those are of health and
interest vitamin K by itself is a
compound that benefits bone and improves
bone strength and reduces fractures but
not it has not been studied a lot you
can look it up if I have one publication
a clinical trial I was involved with on
vitamin K
laughter how would you expect one
question says how would I expect by
parathyroid hormone levels to respond to
high doses of vitamin D there's been a
lot of work on that the higher the 25
hydroxy D level the lower the lower the
parathyroid hormone but it's a log-log
relation in other words it takes a big
jump in 25 hydroxy D to lower PTH one
longer question here from Florida
I saw 25 B a level in a new patient that
was eighty five nanograms per milliliter
it was so odd for these patients that I
got her meds list from the hospital and
behold that she's taking 50,000 for a
month her calcium level is still okay
but I could not believe that error was
not picked up before I did correct it
yes I agree as I indicated we did have
one patient that was very similar one
thing about vitamin D is you know it's
in some ways a good molecule because you
don't have to take it every day it has a
long half-life need to take less often
problem with that is people get a high
dose prescription and take it daily by
mistake so you have to be very careful
with with the intake it seems that
someone who was asking about the no
observed adverse effect level and I'm
obviously didn't quite get those slides
and through the no adverse effect level
for vitamin D was not very clearly
addressed by the Institute of Medicine
likely because it's an ambiguously but
everybody everybody would agree that the
amount of vitamin D that you get from
sunshine is safe because there's never
been any you know indication of disease
toxicity harm due to sunshine exposure
and that number happens to be
approximately 10,000 units per day which
I would regard as the no observed
adverse effect level there's a safety
factor applied to that number about two
and a half and that's where the upper
level the 4,000
per day number comes from there's a
question with regard to sarcoidosis and
why the worst symptoms are from April to
November might that affect relate to
vitamin D toxicity and I don't think so
I don't think that April November the
months where the vitamin D is lowest
sorry
November to April the months where
vitamin D is lowest would cause harm I
cannot answer that question well a lot
of questions here I'm really really
really sorry I can't do them all
how about vitamin D supplementation to
pair up patients with primary
hyperparathyroidism interesting question
primary hyperparathyroidism that kind of
tissue does not respond to feedback from
vitamin D in other words normally
there's a control a feedback loop
between the the 125 D that's produced as
a result of parathyroid hormone and
suppression of PTH so what I'm getting
at is and deal with the primary
hyperparathyroidism first and then
consider more vitamin D because adding
vitamin D to somebody with primary
hyperparathyroidism will evoke a greater
calcium ik response in that scenario is
there a recommendation for vitamin D
with regard to something such as
multiple sclerosis this is a talk that
deals with toxicity and I'm not allowed
to answer that one but we do have
research published in that area so if
you type in to PubMed my name and
multiple sclerosis you'll see some sort
of you know evidence or information on
that area the dark so hard to answer
these questions you said that there is a
capacity
source regard to vitamin D binding
protein you said that Chloe tells you
for all of the capacity of 4,300
nanomoles per liter can you give a
number for the vitamin D binding
eighteen capacity for 25 hydrogen yeah
that's a neat question vitamin D binding
protein holds on to all of the forms of
vitamin D it loves 25 hydroxy D the most
and it has less affinity for the 125 D
so it it holds everything and so if you
have a lot of plain old unmetabolized
vitamin D or 25 hydroxy d they'll both
use up the sites on vitamin D binding
protein almost like a game of musical
chairs where they get the DVP first and
for old 125 D is left to sit alone and
it might then cause a bit of harm if you
have saturation of the binding protein
somebody said it's actually a wonderful
presentation since I'm embarrassed about
could you provide dosages of vitamin D
in terms of diabetic osteoporosis or
heart problems again that's not
something I would be in a position to
offer advice upon and it's an ongoing
research there's not been a lot of
clinical trials except for osteoporosis
with regard to us your proces the
clinical trials have indicated benefit
with 800 units per day and The Endocrine
Society recommends 1,500 to 2,000 units
per day for a physician to advise a
patient concerned about osteoporosis how
do you v8 and UVB play into the process
of processes of vitamin D toxicity
that's again I really love the question
the problem with vitamin D is that
you've got it coming from multiple
social sources from most most of what
you have in your body actually does come
from the skin from ultraviolet light UVB
is the around to 85 to 300 nanometers
wavelength is the color that makes
vitamin D it breaks open the cholesterol
precursor 70 hydro cholesterol UVA can
still cause harm and it does not make
vitamin D some you know part of the
problem here is you could go outside as
the Sun sets or as the sun's
in horizon or during winter UVB
disappears before UVA does so if you've
got marginal lighting still enough to
let's say burn your skin if you're going
skiing a lot of people comment on this
you probably still are not able to make
the vitamin D if it's just UVA getting
through so it's a bit of a shady area
can you comment on vitamin D and it's a
connection to improving autoimmune
disease I'm the one that I'm familiar
with is multiple sclerosis and again
that research is only in the phase 1 /
phase 2 clinical trial stage there is
promising evidence with regard to at
least multiple sclerosis and I might
again just please take a look at PubMed
and find out for yourself about these
there is nothing with regard to harm
that I've noted on those I'm just going
to try taking another can drugs such a
such as tropical topical psoriasis
treatment influence the safe levels of
vitamin D in people with psoriasis
psoriasis is really interesting because
ultraviolet light makes vitamin D within
the skin and the skin is a special
tissue it has both the 25 hydroxy leis
and the one hydroxylase weed in it so we
know that sunshine benefits psoriasis
that makes the symptoms diminish and
it's at least partly due to the local
production of 125 within that tissue
calcitriol
is a vitamin d analogue that is applied
topically onto psoriasis you're putting
the final hormone 125 directly onto the
skin but they do not affect the risk of
any harm with regard to taking a vitamin
D supplement for the rest of your body
the topical treatments are topical and
they don't mean a lot once you get in
does the vitamin D receptor polymorphism
play any role with regard to vitamin D
toxicity
it's a again an interesting question but
there is no polymorphism for the vitamin
D receptor that I know of that amplifies
the response to the 125 the only
polymorphism or rare genetic defect that
one may have with regard to vdr is an
inability to sense the 125 D it's the
type 2 vitamin D resistant rickets
so the polymorphisms I would not think
they have a role to play with regard to
D toxicity here's a question that from
st. Joseph University Hospitals
Staffordshire there are a few recent
papers showing safe replenishment of low
vitamin D with those patients with
calcium below three millimoles per liter
with primary hyperparathyroidism what do
I advise okay so it's a good question
again because I was suggesting that in
primary hyperparathyroidism to give more
vitamin D my advice is I honestly don't
know because I'm not aware of any
clinical trials I know the one study
that showed that modest replacement with
vitamin D didn't raise the calcium any
higher but again my approach would be to
deal with the primary
hyperparathyroidism and get that dealt
with and then consider further vitamin D
I don't know if there's any upside with
regard to giving vitamin D and primary
hyperparathyroidism
do you think that 125 D could indirectly
be measuring magnesium at the tissue
level as opposed to the one percent
magnesium level in serum used clinically
no I don't think that 125 D is any kind
of a surrogate with regard to magnesium
I'm not aware of it I've always seen so
much you know discussion about magnesium
but when you actually try to get into
the literature there's very little that
it can be found about it I'm sorry about
that lack of evidence it's often
surprising how little evidence there is
to the obvious kinds of questions um
what should the levels of 25 hydroxy D
be in elderly patients this is again a
contentious issue because at least in
North America the official number is you
want 25 D to be higher than 55 0 nano
moles per liter or above 20 nanograms
per milliliter and officially that's
appropriate however if you look at
medical decision making groups such as
The Endocrine Society or osteoporosis
groups they quite consistently advise 25
hydroxy DS to be higher than 30
nanograms per milliliter or above 75
nanomoles per liter
I find it funny that thank you for doing
these tops electronically it would be
difficult to attend otherwise sorry for
the electric riches but what would be
what would you consider the optimal 25
Hydra CD level to be might it be 60 to
70 nanograms per milliliter or 32 or
even 50 nanograms per milliliter it's a
very wide range the talk here was
dealing with potential harm as you can
see there are effectively gradations as
you're going toward greater risk of
toxicity by the same token the potential
for a benefit is going through
statistical shades of gray in other
words it's extremely difficult to say at
what point when it reached answer as an
optimal number you know if you think
about the conservative advice from the
Institute's of Medicine they say that
everybody should have a 25 hydroxy D
above 20 nanograms per milliliter 15
animals per liter well if that were the
case if 20 were the bottom end of the
bell curve where would the average be in
other words the top of the bell curve it
would be closer than 30 nanograms per
milliliters or even the most
conservative advice Institute of
Medicine if you take their numbers
seriously they advise that for bone
health the average individual should
have a 25 hydroxy that's 30 nanograms
per milliliter or 75 nano moles per
liter which is not that far off from
what advocates advises a minimum so
don't think that you have to aim for 20
aim for 75 so that you can be sure
you've got it don't think you have to
aim for 20 nanograms per milliliter aim
for 30 nanograms per milliliter so
you're sure of being above 20
I think I'm sure of running out of steam
with regard to answering questions if
there's any one last one let me know
hello